617 830 4750 is the number we are taking
all questions who's next on the phone
with me um this is Connor Connor were
you calling from I'm from State College
Pennsylvania pennant like Penn State
very nice all right what's on your mind
um I actually tweeted you this question
but it was a little long so I understand
why didn't answer but ok um basically
what it was is that my roommate who is
the complete opposite me where I'm
progressive just like you know you uh he
he is trying to say that through some
sort of WikiLeaks email that Hillary
Clinton is more to life than what we
really think on health care and that she
wants the Obamacare to fail in order to
push a single-payer system or public
option and I was trying to get your pain
on this because i think it's complete
nonsense and you think for some reason
that uh legit i don't i don't know what
really makes him think that and i just
think that ever since the nineties you
know that she's not for single-payer
okay so if i understand correctly the
idea is publicly Hillary Clinton says
she is for strengthening Obamacare but
in reality she does want single-payer
but it would be sort of optically bad to
say I want to get rid of Obamacare so
really she wants Obamacare to just fail
and then she can swoop in and say hey we
tried it it failed how about single
payer is that sort of your roommates
idea yeah that's what it seems to be uh
even includes Obama in that well not
even to fillory but that's why I think
it's bad but i just think of what you
are thought of that I mean listen big
picture it's rare that politicians and
elected officials make plans that would
uh require many years beyond their 10
year to be resolved right because they
really want they want credit for stuff
so in general what you're talking about
stands you know somewhere like a 10 to
50
in your project institute Obamacare let
it run its course fail propose the
single-payer so it's it's really forward
it requires a lot of forethought and
generally just elected officials don't
usually think that way they think in
terms of election cycle so that's like
the big picture thing at the micro level
exactly at the micro level we've heard
from Hillary Clinton from some of her
speeches and where she presumably was
speaking more candidly and there's been
nothing to suggest that she wants
Obamacare to fail to put in single-payer
I mean I just don't think there's any
evidence for that yeah exactly met with
the way out thing unit cuz he included
Obama so out like Obama is way more into
the legacy then even Hillary Clinton
probably so like why would he want what
he hasn't named ought to fail private of
dollars crazy and want to see what you
thought about it yeah Connor I agree
with your assessment i think absent some
specific evidence which i haven't seen
any i wouldn't buy it alright thank you
so much for the call really appreciate
it gamefly is sort of like netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / tdps the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com / tdps